c'est pour vous montrer des images
différentes mais en fait c'est
exactement la même réalité c'est juste
qu'avant vous avez de la propagande des
élevages nettoyer des animaux qu'on a
enlevé les cadavres et c'est exactement
les pratiques les mêmes pourquoi si
c'est bien bonne ou mauvaise de le faire
il n'y a pas de bonne façon de faire
quelque chose de mal il n'y a pas de
façon correcte de le faire quand comment
ce monsieur peut dire que c'est quelque
chose de naturel
alors que caen perte de gamage vous avez
une mortalité de 10 à 20 fois supérieur
que d'habitude c'est faux ça et si il
faut bien sûr que sessegnon mais moi je
suis producteur donc je sais mieux
comment que la démo retenu par une
demande faible quoi très très faible
mais je m'en sers au même régime à
partir sur mars et deuxièmement donc
c'est à 0 60% restants finale chasse à
l'abattoir animaux dont 10 ou
électrocutés mais c'est archi faux
les services vétérinaires et qui font
bien leur boulot contrôler régulièrement
les abattoirs chez nous et chez et chez
les autres on verra bien là chez nous et
encore il ya huit jours ils sont passés
je peux vous dire donc ils vérifient de
près les animaux ils sont anesthésiés
avec un appareil électrique sané
électrocute pas du tout un canard qui
électrocute et il ne saigne pas il est
honteux ça commercial les saignées juste
après 10 la viande
le reportage là donc ils disent des
conneries n'importe quoi s'est inséré
dans l'orient l'afrique
l'argument économique ça ne tient pas
parce qu'il ya une telle propagande pour
le foie gras que tout le monde va
essayer de s'en procurer au prix le plus
bas et le prix le plus bas
ce sont des animaux qui sont exploitées
de cette manière soit en france soit à
l'étranger puisqu'il ya le même de
l'importation de foie gras ou les
animaux sont vraiment traiter encore
pire créé les images qu'on vient de voir
et quatre dans sa note il s'agit pas de
dire du jour au lendemain
supprimons la filière il s'agit de faire
prendre conscience aux gens que ce
qu'ils mangent à une histoire une
origine cette histoire cette origine on
le voit dans ces images et là j'entends
de la part des partisans
oui oui cet affreux mais continuons en
bouffer par la regrette c'est pas
cohérent c'est que tu as cette affreuse
à gaza
ces festivals et le bob gavage la
manière dont ils sont tous issus
d'élevages industriels qui surgit madrid
dimanche parler des abattoirs parler des
abattoirs de tous les animaux c'est ça
que je voudrais quand même qu'on est au
bout des choses
est ce que vous êtes contre la
consommation de toutes les viandes oui
bah oui mes bêtes à l'abattoir vous oui
mais eric
d'accord ce que vous avez donc ces bêtes
à l'abattoir de toute façon en soit en
situation de stress
évidemment règne pour le transport on va
pas la jouer autrement
donc soit on est totalement cohérent en
mangent pas de viande du tout soit on
comprend que techniquement il ya des
situations de stress total pardon j'ai
pardonné si on ferme sa gueule mais
voilà mais je suis d'accord parce que
franchement mérité mais c'est tout ou
rien alors oui pardon les l'histoire de
l'électricité c'est pour pas que
l'animal souffre c'est à dire que parce
que les abattages sans étourdissement
pardon c'est bien pire que ça donc il ya
un moment il faut quand même bien sûr
que le mot courant ça fait peur mais
c'est vous pas que les animaux souffrent
minutes le donc dans ces cas là arrêtons
tout la viande mais larry vous avez
raison mais c'est obligatoire à par les
services vétérinaires il vérifie
vraiment ces animaux sont tous tous tous
anesthésié et ça ne rapporte jamais 600
vidéos rassure vincent dizaine des
dizaines de vidéos qu'on vous envoie ses
canards reprendre conscience après l'ex
taulard cause ils sont saignés vivent
les iem dire la démunis des vidéos des
services vétérinaires sont vigilants
cooper vient comme ça même dans leurs
oeuvres à toi on nous demande des
services vétérinaires ils viennent à la
maison c'est très bien pour vous vous
n'êtes pas représentatif de ce qui se
passe vous parlez de l'est vers un duel
mais va jusqu'à ses 90 % de ce que les
gens consomment 80 vous n'êtes pas 98,4
ici vous êtes dans l'anecdote du petit
petit élevage familial mais c'est pas
c'est pas ça qui nourrira le monde on
dit que les antispécistes sont dans
l'utopie c'est vous qui êtes dans
l'utopie c'est pas les 60 milliards
d'animaux esclaves qui est qu'on a dans
le monde
il faut qu'on apprenne planète pour les
mettre vous n'auriez pas les gens avec
ça